pop
je vois quand je vous parle du plat-pays
voyez ce que je veux dire oui qu'est ce
que c'est mais c'est le plat comanche
couramment le plus fréquemment dans le
plat pays en belgique qu'est ce que
c'est et bien c'est toujours le les
frites le steak et la pierre avez vous
l'impression que la belgique soit un
pays de cocagne
non monsieur pas du tout j'étouffe par
la boisson ici c'est plutôt la bière je
trouve que le lac au pin du coca alors à
votre avis qui tient les rênes en
belgique
attention il n'y a pas plusieurs est
logique qu'une reine en belgique et à
s'appelle fabiola et c'est son mari qui
la tient la couronne n'est pas menacé
dans votre pays en belgique
ben non chez nous on n'a pas le cran et
csi sallefranque la couronne c'est
plutôt la tipp slovaques qu'ils
souhaitent le norvège et le danemark
le belge est il cartésien oui monsieur
le chauffeur de taxi le garçon de café
le barman qu'est ce qui vous fait dire
ça parce que j'ai été dans
le métier et je sais que le barman
il ya son café le portier joue beaucoup
gardent vous n'êtes pas cartésien romeo
monsieur et non pas du tout non je n'ai
pas de jouer aux cartes
le belge est il sédentaires à votre avis
qu'est-ce qui pour quelles raisons
est-ce que c'est sédentaires oui oui je
sais mauvaise dans qui perdent leur
temps
et c'est le cas des belges le belge est
il le sens de l'accueil
eh bien écoutez le belge accueil très
très très bien la preuve si vous allez
par exemple du côté de louis pion ici à
namur
eh bien nous avons les meilleurs
cueilleur de fraises les primeurs les
poires tout ce qui s'ensuit
ce sont des bons qu'ailleurs ici en
belgique le belge est-il utopiste ou
casanière votre avis non à mon avis le
belge s'est plutôt casanier quito pistre
qu'est ce que c'est utopiste en faut
quand même pas nous prendre pour des
sauvages un utopiste c'est plutôt ceux
qui vivent dans des huttes comme le
[ __ ] tout ça disons les autres plutôt
un cuisinier un casanier ce sont ceux
qui sont déjà renfermé entre quatre murs
et dans une cabane et alors vous êtes
plutôt à je serais plutôt casey du côté
casanier c'est-à-dire déjà dans un
appartement un peu convenable et pas
utopiste mais vous me disiez que c'était
bon c'était les utopistes c'était plutôt
du côté des sauvages mais ce soir on n'a
pas encore vu c'est en belgique
l'autochtone belge ça vous dit rien
on parlait de notre temps ne sera pas le
répéter
notre nouvelle à l'automne ou belge
l'autochtone belge l'autochtone
l'autochtone belge
l'auteur thunder qu'est ce que c'est une
voiture et vous connaissez
après citons la promiscuité en belgique
voyez déjà ce que c'est que la
promiscuité est certainement ce n'est
pas
par exemple lors des fiançailles que
l'on va sculpter pour la raison ce n'est
pas vraiment une coutume en belgique de
de se quitter parce que en effet assis
ou qui ont fait la fête
maric les dessins de beugin dans le
temps c'était plutôt en définition que
l'on fêté hommage et on buvait la gueuse
lors la promiscuité ça serait quoi
ben ça c'est plutôt la fiancée qui ce
but parce que
les fiancés que havas mari mais je ne
pense pas que ça se fait plutôt en
belgique dont on apprécie la promiscuité
en belgique
je ne pense pas est-ce que le belge est
lunatique en général à votre avis non
les âges et seulement les jeunes savants
ils n'ont pas forcément acquise et des
lunettes
ce sont plutôt les plus âgés qui suit la
lecture la télévision mais enfin c'est
tout n'est pas lunatique ou même nom que
des bonzes et appréciez vous les
calembours ça peut aller
voyez ce que c'est que calembours et à
peu près comme des gens qui
sinon c'est un légume c'est un légume
qui se mange avec les anguilles des
calembours
oui vous êtes vous appréciez les
calembours comme j'aime pas les
anguilles enfin on avait une fois fait
mais j'aimais pas tellement il en guise
j'aime pas les 15 ans guillot vers sète
les anguilles aux verts ils mettent des
calembours dedans alors commençons les
calembours qu'est ce que c'est
ben c'est comme seul sait faire et ça se
fait cuire et les on dit et vous
appréciez les calembours vous même oui
j'aime bien de temps en temps c'est un
goût différent différent de d un peu
comme des artichauts mais c'est quand
même vous différents quoi c'est un on
trouve ça uniquement en belgique
[Musique]